Swedish historian Johan Norberg is the
author of The capitalist Manifesto why
the global free market will save the
world which caught the eye of Elon Musk
who recently tweeted this book is an
excellent explanation of why capitalism
is not just successful but morally right
Norberg wrote the book to combat a
growing belief on the right and the left
that libertarian values of individual
autonomy property rights limited
government and free enterprise are
failing to raise living standards and
need to be ditched in favor of more
centralized power and control over
virtually all aspects of Our Lives a
senior fellow at the KO Institute
Norberg shows that life is actually
getting better for all of us especially
the world's poor and that economic
globalization political liberalization
and cultural Freedom are the main
drivers of
improvement Johan Norberg thanks for
talking to Reon pressure is on mine uh
uh first off let's start what's the
elevator pitch uh or do swedes call it
the lift in English what do you go with
is it a lift or an elevator we call it a
hiss a hiss okay sorry about that what
is the hiss pitch you know for uh the
capitalist Manifesto well the his pitch
is that um you know we have wide
discontent with capitalism and free
markets and free trade it seems like uh
politicians on all continents have all
agreed that we need to repatriate
production redistribute resources that
inequality in global warming shows us
that that free markets doesn't work and
my point is that on each of in every
area free markets entrepreneurs
innovators have performed spectacularly
well and that most of these things have
been misunderstood and even in the 21st
Century I mean the past 20 years you
know or or so have been pretty good even
though there's a lot of people that you
and I have kind of been allies with
ideologically over the years who are
like oh yeah yeah it was great up until
2000 and now it's all gone to let's
start by talking about yeah it was like
about 20 years ago that you and I I
think first talked and you were pushing
a book called inde defense of global
capitalism kind of sketch out what was
what were the circumstances that that
book needed to be
manifested well they were the same as
they are today politicians and interest
groups blamed global capitalism and free
trade for all the problems of the world
back then a leftist uh current of uh
anti- globalization and U reducing free
trade around the world and I thought I
had to gather the argument cuz I thought
that was I was seeing around the world
was that the very countries that began
to integrate into the global economy
they did better than they had ever done
before poverty was decreasing
opportunities were were improving and um
cutting them off from globalization
would destroy that yeah what were the
big arguments emanating and I mean it
was I guess it was Center and the center
from the center going towards the left
especially the right wi seemed to be at
least in America was broadly supportive
of GL globalization and trade and you
know George HW Bush had started NAFTA
Bill Clinton who was a Centrist Democrat
you know finish the job and everything
but you know we were high off of winning
the Cold War but by the end of the
decade you had people dressing like sea
turtles and smashing Starbucks and
McDonald's in Seattle what was the main
complaint coming from the anti-g
globalizers then well it wasn't
portrayed as a Justice movement the very
idea that yes multinational companies
and big Brands and free trade they might
benefit us in the rich world but it will
come at a terrible cost in poor
countries exploitation widening
inequalities increasing poverty so
basically a serome idea about how the
world works if we benefit they will lose
and ironically I get the same thing
today but the positions have been
reversed okay yeah let's talk about that
uh because yeah I mean you Flash Forward
20 uh 20 years or so and and it seems
like it's more right-wingers are now
saying you know what we need to nail
down the borders we need to build more
walls uh globalization benefits these
Global you know corporations not the
little guy quite right and actually they
sound very much like attack did 20 years
ago this French left-wing protectionist
organization but now from a rightwing
nationalist perspective and in a way
they have the same idea that the world
is a serious some game but this time
around they think that we are losing
because everybody has seen with their
own eyes that capitalism is the greatest
thing that has ever happened to the
world's poor we've reduced extreme
poverty by 135,000 people every day
since I wrote in defense of global
capitalism now lots of people in the
west and in the US they see that and
think that but they still have the idea
that the world is a Ser some game so
they must be thinking that somebody else
has got to be losing out so probably we
are this time around losing good jobs
de-industrialization and widening
inequalities back home right and you
know let's you know part of the argument
and I think what's really urgent about
the capitalist Manifesto besides you
know the title and and a defense of it
is like you actually work through a
bunch of things around the globe but
also in the United States and in Europe
you know things are getting better um
you know uh let's uh talk about um you
know General standards of living have
increased you know how do you how do you
measure that and how do you how do you
demonstrate that
yeah and I mean I can see I wake up
every morning thinking that the world is
going to the dogs as well because we got
all these disasters shocks we have
financial crisis inflation pandemics
Wars and stuff like that so I I can
sympathize why it looks bad and but
that's why we need something more than
just looking at headlines and trying to
feel our way to to a world view we have
to look at indicators of living
standards and then we can see things
like how um extreme poverty every uh
every day we complained about neol
liberalism destroying the world
135,000 people were raised out of
extreme poverty around a third of all
the wealth that mankind has ever
attained if we measure it by GDP per
capita was produced over these 20 years
which is pretty impressive iive even
though some of it might be coming from
debt and um other worrying
circumstances a third of all the wealth
ever it's it's impressive looking at
indicators like um child mortality it's
been reduced by almost half over 20
years meaning 4 million fewer children
died last year than in 2002 despite all
the headwinds despite the pandemic and
the all the um slippage that we had back
then
um you at one point you quote uh Bono
from you too talking about how you know
he was he was a big Crusader for ending
Global poverty and he was like hey you
know what we kind of won and it was done
through trade not through Aid can you
talk a little bit about it's not just
that these things were reduced but it's
it was done through
globalization exactly I mean it doesn't
didn't happen everywhere poverty has
increased in certain places and hunger
as well but in in the countries that
have managed to reform liberalize
integrate into specifically Global
Supply chains they've been able to raise
their productivity dramatically that's
where we're seeing the U the reduction
in poverty increasing living standards
specifically many Asian countries like
Vietnam and Bangladesh Indonesia India
and China we've seen tremendous progress
they are doing what we did over 50 to
100 years in in just 20 years well how
does that compare comped to uh at one
point you talk about how in the early
60s and you know in the first kind of
burst after
decolonization it looked like Africa was
going to be you know the the the
continent on the grow and it was
actually doing phenomenally well and
Asia was doing terribly and you know now
those are I mean it's not there are some
parts of Africa that are doing well but
it's mostly reversed um what what
happened there yeah no that's
interesting when you go back and listen
to development economists and leftist
economists like gunar Mall in the 19 M
who famously or notoriously and angrily
shared the Nobel Prize with Hayek right
he was like I I don't want to go if I'm
sharing it with this insane right-wing
reactionary exactly because mutal knew
who understood the world he saw African
countries that they had strong
governments they had a strong natural
resource base and they would see
tremendous growth in the future whereas
Asia would be racked by problems and
yeah all they had were people in rice
right you know whereas all the minerals
in the world were in Africa exactly and
of course that's what destroyed many
African economies it created a resource
curse it made a few people incredibly
wealthy so everybody fought over power
instead where the places that didn't
have much of Natural Resources metals
and minerals well they had to instead
work harder and it work smarter rather
than harder and uh beginning to
integrate first with
Hong Kong Singapore Taiwan South Korea
trying to understand how do we fit in an
international division of labor and then
attracting foreign investments and
trading with the rest of the world and
being the first of the new wave of poor
countries really integrating into the
developed world and I mean you show
strong correlations between economic
freedom and wealth um is does anybody
really challenge that anymore
no one who looks at the data challenges
that I don't really think you can see
it's such a strong correlation first
country starting to reduce extreme
poverty it's Britain early in the 19th
century then we have a next wave of
Western European countries uh we get
Germany America then eventually in the
mid 19th century Sweden and the
Scandinavian countries late 19th century
it's Japan and then in the next wave the
first countries in in East Asia the
Tigers and what happened at that precise
moment I mean it's it's a matter of
within minutes almost after having
starting to liberalize markets securing
property rights trading with the rest of
the world then it takes off and you know
on the theme of tigers there's the
Celtic tiger right Ireland which my
grandparents my father's Grand uh my
father's parents came from for a
thousand years partly because of
colonialism I was there imperialism
mostly because of bad governance I mean
what does the rise of Ireland in the
late 20th century say of like do you
need the right people to be living there
in order to get stuff done or is it
mostly a systems-based approach that if
you free up the economy you know anybody
can become rich well what I've learned
from economic history is that it happens
in the most unexpected places and that's
what we can tell from the old forecasts
by all these mistaken economists who
thought that it can only happen in
certain places and at a certain time
well you know that's what they say until
unexpected places begin to to liberalize
you know in Ireland I remember reading a
Swedish newspaper article about Ireland
some 10 years ago and they had this
little box with facts that they
apparently took from an encyclopedia and
it said that even though it wasn't
related to the article at all because
the article was about sort of Ireland
success but in that box it said that oh
it's a hopelessly poor country and
everybody's leaving it and this was such
a sharp contrast because the people
hadn't changed it was the institutions
suddenly the incentive to to work and
take risks and it also puts to mind or
puts to rest the idea I remember I
started at reason 30 years ago and there
were a lot of people who were kind of
chasing uh the dragon of Max Faber or
something they're saying well you know
Catholic countries in Europe were poor
they have to be poor because Catholics
whatever you know they take too many
days off for holy days of obligation or
whatever you know they don't eat enough
meat on Fridays and then yeah it's like
yeah maybe religion doesn't explain it
you know IQ doesn't explain it it I mean
it's kind of liberalism right liberal
governance and Max vber famously had to
write about why Asian economies doesn't
de get developed and basically saying
naming the precise factors that
everybody's now mentioning to to explain
the success of Asia he took that
confusion ISM and strong families rather
than individualism those are the things
that makes it impossible for them to to
thrive but then after 1979 in China
after 1991 in India suddenly they just
take off and then everybody is talking
about oh it's this Asian mentality and
in China it's confusion ISM and it's the
strong families that creates trust and
the collectivism that we saw what the
200 Beijing Olympic opening games where
there seem to be a billion Chinese
beating drums in the stadium that is
yeah um in America um you know a lot of
people would say well you know what
since uh you know China joined the World
Trade Organization in the 21st century
we have just seen you know massive
de-industrialization the Midwest is you
know is beyond the Rust Belt um you know
everything has gone to hell in the
United States um that's not really true
right I mean among other things you talk
about how income
Mobility you know income Mobility is
either increasing or it has been
constant since
1971 what's going on there yeah the
middle class is shrinking but that's
because it's moving up if you look at
those indicators and and specifically if
you look at not just dollars and and
cents um we should do that too because
the it's important to lat to rest the
whole idea of wage stagnation which was
really a period in the 1970s and 80s
when many sectors had increased wages
much faster than productivity and they
had to scale that back unless they
otherwise they would have been destroyed
completely but after 1990 we've seen
rapid wage increases in in in the US 30
to 60% depending on whether you take in
full compensation including non-monetary
like health insurance and stuff but also
it's important to mention
goods and services it's not dollars and
cents we wanted we want to be able to
buy something and we can see how how
most amenities that were considered
luxuries just decades ago are now
getting close to 100% distribution in
the US people under under the poverty
threshold in the US now own more
amenities like um TV sets washing
machines uh dryers and of course
computers and cell phones then the
average American had in 1970 so it seems
like not everything was destroyed and
why is that well one reason is that we
did de-industrialized in the meaning
fewer people have to work in factories
to create the goods we want we haven't
de-industrialized in an absolute sense
we we produce more than probably at any
other stage in in America's history uh
but it's been a success story it's the a
rise of productivity which means that we
can make it the goods more comp with
automation make the goods more compe
comptitive and affordable to most people
that's what successful countries do
that's what I mean even China is losing
manufacturing jobs around 5 million
manufacturing jobs a uh year in the past
decade because they're moving up the
value chain they are getting better jobs
with higher productivity there's a great
section in uh the capitalist Manifesto
where you talk about kind of the myth of
you know working in Detroit in the 1950s
s and the peak of industrial workers in
the United States as a share of the the
uh labor force was actually in the 40s
so it was already declining in the 50s
but you know people would say oh it was
great to be an auto worker in Detroit in
the 50s I think you had a stat in there
where what was it like uh 10% of the GDP
or something was coming out of Detroit
but it actually wasn't that good can you
talk a bit about that yeah it looked
good compared to the rest of the economy
because it was awful working in
agriculture and in domestic uh
traditional industry so comparatively it
was better than in many other places but
now when we have this kind of nostalgic
Rose tinted image of what it was like
it's important to go back and there are
some historical projects interviewing
the workers who really did the job and
they're telling us first of all I do
this so that my son will not have to
stand work in a factory like this
because it is awful it's dangerous it's
dirty and you can lose an arm or two if
you're if you're not careful um and also
very insecure jobs very rapid turnover
uh and when I look at different cohorts
it turns out that there's one cohort in
Detroit the uh year of
1953 they had Fairly secure jobs got a
good decent wage unionized and so the
whole myth of sort of Western Manu
facturing Utopia back the grave you know
uh employment you know generous benefits
all of this is based on one city in one
year and what did they get the ones who
got those best jobs well adjusted for
inflation they get what you would get as
a starting wage in Amazon warehouse
today um you yet you know in the United
States we see uh and I'm not sure if
this uh correlates throughout Europe or
or globally but uh certainly among men
of prime kind of work years there's
lower Workforce participation rates than
there used to be uh there's also deaths
of Despair um let's first talk about
Workforce participation rates is it a
good thing or a bad thing that fewer men
you know between the ages of 25 and 54
are actively in the labor
force yeah if if people are able to work
and and want to work that's it's a good
thing they should they shouldn't be
doing other things that has been
declining uh but it has been declining
for a very long time that's important to
point out this is not something that
happened when China entered the World
Trade Organization did not happen with
NAFTA it started after the second world
war basically and it was actually much
faster the the increase in men outside
of the labor force uh was much higher
rate in the
1950s 60s and70s then in this era of
globalization so it tells you that
there's something else going on than
just competition it seems like we are
pretty bad at retraining and having
Mobil the kind of mobility in the
workforce that we we would want but most
of these people are then counted as as
disabled and they're in various programs
rather than standing in in the workforce
you um for a a project that you did a
video project as well as other things
you actually went around the United
States and you talked to people who were
on welfare who were getting various
kinds of um you know supplemental income
and things like that what did you find
in that because that that also is I mean
the the the stuff itself is great and
then in the capitalist Manifesto when
you recap that what was going on with
that how did how did they describe you
know who they were and what they were up
yeah well I learned that you have to be
very smart and hardworking to be poor
and unemployed in in the US because the
systems are so incredibly complex and
they come from a wide variety of sources
and they're based on different metrics
and they then are also um discounted or
and lost at various points when you make
more of an income than you used to so
what they told me is that it feels
hopeless it feels like there's nothing
they can do to change their their situ
situation uh one of them told me that
doing the calculations from four
different benefit systems if she
increases her wage from 29,000 to 30,000
so many of the benefits full away so
that she just makes
15,000 half of it so it means that the
in a way the marginal tax rate for the
poor and unemployed is much higher than
for the rich and they're calculating
this either implicitly or explicitly
they they kind of understand yeah they
know that it's it's hopeless basically
to to go out there and sacrifice time
energy and transportation costs to to
get a job because they noticed that they
don't make money is is there you know
probably not is there an easy solution
to that I you know and this is you know
I when we were talking about factories I
was like God you know I worked in
factories and anybody who worked in a
factory never
romanticizes factory work it's just it's
definitely shitty compared to any
non-factory job but I remember you know
in a privileged setting I when I moved
from grad school in Buffalo to take a
job at reason uh my wife and I at the
time we realized after we had moved that
we basically went our our uh grad
Student stiens in Buffalo which had a
low cost of living we had free health
care through the university we were
expecting our first child we were doing
so much better than when we went to one
salary starting at reason in La that it
was like God if we had thought about it
economically we never would have done it
but it was also we were playing the long
game is there you know and you take a
hit in earnings now in order to
conceivably be doing the work you want
down the road at better pay is there a
policy solution to getting people who
are you know say making 29 Grand on
welfare to say you know what you should
take a hit you know so that in 5 years
you're doing spectacularly well yeah
well I wish welfare is complicated and
it's there are no perfect social benefit
system the moment you start paying uh
people when they are unemployed and
disabled you also subsidize it you also
buy more more of it and it's difficult
to get out of it but there are versions
of kind of a negative income tax that
would at least make sure that you
always keep more of what earn so you you
don't create suddenly a 50% marginal tax
rate or something like that yes and uh
at least and and you know so that you
don't have to do all these calculations
and feel like it's It seems impossible
many of them I talk to they have friends
and and relatives who are helping them
to do the calculations and they're
sitting there with with pen and paper
and trying to find out is there any way
to improve uh my life well with just one
simple system it it's never simple but
just one at least you'd see You'd
understand you know what you can do to
improve your life is is that uh an
argument for a universal basic income or
a negative income tax do you think that
you know people know that there's this
lower limit that they can't drop behind
below but that's also that's it I don't
you know it doesn't seem like the Ubi
works out well when it's actually
implemented but but it is an argument in
favor of an Ubi and then there might be
bigger problems that makes us a little
bit cautious when it comes to doing it
it seems like a Ubi would be incredibly
expensive if everybody's supposed to
have it or it wouldn't help the poorest
much so perhaps some sort of negative
income tax with which sort of ensures or
supports wages for the poorest seems
like a better way to go about this uh
okay but what now let's talk about
deaths of Despair um which are
probably you know one of the main
examples that people will say where you
know Norberg if you're saying life is
getting better in America you know we
have consecutive years even you know the
pandemic obviously helps us but it
doesn't explain all of it you know where
lifespans are declining in America in
the 21st century um can you quickly
Define what deaths of of Despair are and
then what did you find when you start
looking into what's going on with that
yeah well it's a famous and depressing
concept coined by Angus Deon the Nobel
laurat and his wife and case Deon deaths
of Despair and they're including various
sorts of self harm broadly speaking
could be drug overdosis um alcoholism or
suicide uh I think when we look at it
this is kind of controversial among
Scholars because when you look at it it
might be that we're just talking about a
drug overdose epidemic that that's the
real thing that that sets this apart but
what they're meaning and what many take
away from it is that there there's
something related to how people live a
sense of Despair that makes them live in
this kind of self-destructive way and
this has increased dramatically why is
that yes many say that this is it's
strange as society as the society gets
richer and and more open some blame it
then
on ruthless capitalism and free markets
but as um Angus Deon points out himself
you can hear it in the very word of
globalization it's Global it happens
everywhere and so is automation so are
all these forces it's but it seems like
it's specifically happening in the US uh
rather than in other places and
economically more economically free
countries in the west have not had the
same increase in in uh deaths of Despair
to this extent
so and it's not equally distributed
among the United States right you know
where California and New York seem to
have lower rates than you know Ohio and
Kentucky that's right and it's a
traditional um white blue color working
class uh that's out of the labor force
that it's mostly uh people who are have
ended up on again the disability
benefits and the welfare benefit traps
and and feels like there's not much they
can do to change their lives and and
that's not specifically then related to
uh anything that has happened with
global globalization to automation
because this was a group that ended up
quicker in that section of of out of the
workforce and stuff like that before uh
we even thought of NAFTA and and the
World Trade Organization we saw more
jobs being lost in the Rust Belt in the
1960s and70s than in the past few
decades if anything we've seen more of a
a stagnation since then and and
inequality uh you know is flat in the
United States or declining globally it's
declining inequality among
countries um so what do you do with
deaths of Despair is it is it a category
you know that I mean it commands
attention but is it ultimately you know
is is it something that is beyond the
scope of of government or a you know
kind of a modern society to deal with or
or is it U you know a a fundamental
misreading of how people live I don't
well I mean one thing is this might be
very much a drug overdose uh epidemic
rather than anything else so perhaps
there are things related to drug loss
and the uh unsafe drugs that are being
used on the market closely uh you know
tracked with the rise of opioids
particularly
Oxycontin and I know uh you know other
people who deal with ad addiction and
whatnot they say you know the it it's
not that people weren't taking drugs
before it's that drugs are more potent
they also there was a Crackdown on
oxycontin and other opioids so then
people turn to black markets for either
versions of that or heroin which which
is risky particularly in a black market
so you get more deaths quite right so
this this is one angle don't think too
much about Lifestyles and stuff just
make sure that people don't poison
themselves with something that they
don't know what it what it's about but
the other thing is that we know that
it's bad for your health and you shorten
your life if you
feel like you're worthless it's
impossible to change your situation
you're not need it anywhere and this is
I think one of the greatest challenges
to um modern welfare states like uh
americaas because it seems like
economically I mean it's it's all right
we can probably afford to to have a
larger group of people outside of the
workforce we can pay for it all and hand
them benefits and they stay at home but
can we afford what it buys this kind
this sense of being rejected not needed
anywhere and not being able to change
your life circumstances so I think there
are both things to do with the benefit
system but also obviously making sure
that the thresholds to getting new jobs
once you once you've lost it uh it's
incredibly important that they're as as
low as possible and goes to occupational
licensing stuff it goes to the whole
housing market the fact that it's
impossible to live where the jobs are uh
nowadays because of uh very much a
regulatory issue right um you know
another Excel Ator supposedly in the
decline of Lifestyle in or standards of
living in the United States you know has
to do with China all you know China I
was just watching Donald Trump a couple
days ago was talking to uh people in
Michigan directed at blue collar and he
was saying China China China you know
China has taken all the jobs there's a
version of that that Joe Biden says and
Democrats everywhere in America you have
a chapter called China paper tiger so
are you saying or or Adventure argument
that you know what China is not going to
eat the world right there is one
unifying narrative about China that I
get a lot from both the left and the
right and the center and it's that
they're so incredibly smart and they
have a plan for everything how to invade
our markets and take our jobs with very
um clever industrial policy and picking
certain companies subsidizing them and
dumping their goods here and buy they
cheat right they steal intellectual
property everybody follows the
government right the orders come down
and they're instantly executed yeah and
that's not true and and and must say the
worrying implication is that so many
Americans say we have to imitate them we
have to be like that in order to beat
them and that's one reason why we get
this support for protectionism and
Industrial policy right now uh you know
they do have Industrial policy they are
trying to pick winners they are trying
to get the heavy hand of of the
government back into the economy but
that's a fairly new phenomena I mean
this H started to happen around the
global financial crisis and especially
after Ching ping took power and this is
not what's making China Rich this is
what risks making it poor it's a
terrible destruction of resources that
are going on and you can see that that
they're handing the subsidies the cheap
credits to the least productive
companies and they become less
productive once they do this it's very
important I think to get the history of
China's economic rise right and it's
showing lower than average growth of
Asian countries right over the past
several years and things like that so it
like whatever I mean in in the United I
don't know how this played out in Sweden
or in Europe in the 80s but you know we
did a version of this with Japan and the
role of China where I was told you know
going to college in the 80s like you
better learn Japanese because we're all
going to be working for a Japanese
company and you know within a couple
years Japan Japanese businessmen
famously bought Rockefeller Center you
know the a great Monument to American
Ingenuity and capitalism and we're like
okay game up and then it was like yeah a
couple years later they unloaded it at a
loss yeah um you do you think something
similar is going uh or something similar
is at work with our fears of China oh I
I think so for sure China had a good it
was an impressive rise and it happened
precisely in the areas where they began
to liberalize and open up big time uh so
it was a success of of Market forces in
China now that's over uh they've begun
to uh Retreat the government is back in
in business and that's really
undermining business and it comes at a
very bad time China is still a very poor
country it's I mean it's just that it's
big but it's as po as the Dominican
Republic or Gabon uh so they would need
if they wanted to go on the trajectory
of of Japan Taiwan and and South Korea
Japan under their good years then they
would have to grow 5 to 7% per capita
for a couple more decades that is not
happening uh partly also for demographic
reasons we U we have fewer Farmers to
put into factories so the catch-up
growth is over fewer Farmers to put into
newly built Apartments to the real
estate boom is over they are they are in
Decline so the question is will this be
a managed decline or will it be a will
it end in tears yeah what what what's
your guess I mean one of the other
things about China when after Mao uh
died and China liberalized it seemed
again in the 80s really Milton
Friedman's maximum that first you get
economic Liberty and then you demand
political Liberty was taking place and
then you know tanks rolled into tmn
square and it was like oh no they're
going back to dictatorship which seemed
to be working because that was the way
that people like Thomas fredman and
other kind of
early uh kind of champions of GL of
managed globalization we're like oh no
we maybe we should be more like China do
you think you know now that China is
facing certain kinds of decline you know
is it going to actually be like yeah you
know what we're we're going to give up
power or is it going to end in tears
yeah that's a good question there was
this very sad time when we had this
dictator Envy all over the US and and
Europe and Thomas fredman famously said
that he wanted to be China for a day and
then he would fix environmental problems
just like that because we yeah it looked
like it worked but what was it that
worked it was really the entrepreneurs
and the innovators who had created stuff
the moment Xi Jinping got back and got
interested in various sectors he began
to destroy them uh so I I think we have
to get that history right because then
we also understand that they're in real
trouble right now and uh just like we
think that if the dictator points
everybody in the the right direction we
must remember when he points them in the
wrong direction everything collapses at
the same time and I think we're seeing
more of Investigations like that now one
very interesting thing that is related
to Thomas fredman is that yeah dictators
and and planned economies they're able
to fix things rapidly on paper at least
to get the uh get stuff done but what is
it that they get done so one thing is
that they have now twice as much wind
power wind gener wind farms and than the
us and this is what impressed Thomas
fredman and the rest of the world look
this is how you solve environmental
problems but now when Scholars look at
what's going on those wind that wind
power doesn't generate as much as
America's even though on paper it's
twice as much why not it's less
efficient it doesn't always work
sometimes they're not even connected to
the grid because they didn't produce it
to generate power or to make money they
did it to fulfill the command of chi
jingping and the plans and that's what
we're beginning to realize about China
right now and I think they do too and
who knows why that might be a reason why
we're seeing this new purges of the
party one minister of defense and one
minister of for an aest disappearing in
the past few months uh let's talk a
little bit about the environment because
this is you know a big part of the large
Narrative of pessimism is that you know
some people critics uh you know from
wherever they are in the political
Spectrum or ideological Spectrum will
say okay yeah maybe things are getting
better you know overall but the planet
is about to you know dry up you know
burn up and blow away um is that
accurate actually what we've seen again
over the past few days decades is uh one
of the greatest achievements when it
comes to the environment ever I mean
it's fairly recently we started to care
about the nature and and about the
future now in the past decades we've
reduced most of the pollutants uh
emissions we're beginning to see growth
of forests again in rich countries in
most countries actually around the world
we're beginning to see rewilding going
on cleaner water um all those areas
tremendous achievements and where does
this happen you know if you go to the
environmental performance index looking
at 40 different indicators of
environmental uh conditions around the
world they point out that GDP per capita
is a pretty strong um explainer for
what's going on the Richer you are the
more you can also afford to care about
the planet because you're not making the
decision so the forest or my children's
education you can do both and you can
get better technology to deal with with
it as well and that is not I mean that's
an interesting question from a kind of
libertarian or classical liberal
perspective those I mean some of that is
done through government mandates right
so it's an odd thing like we get richer
and then we demand more a cleaner
environment but that sometimes limits
what goes on in the marketplace quite
right it does um it's not always the
case some of this is driven by consumers
and by businesses just wanting something
better and ER but quite often it's also
some sort of mandates or or taxes do you
define yourself as maybe as neither but
as a Libertarian or an anarchist or you
know what is that a meaningful
distinction for you I'd call myself self
libertarian because nowadays I think we
we need some sort of minimal state to at
least make sure that we have the right
rules to rules for the road um one of
the uh best sections of the book because
in and in a way this is where people who
say the world is getting worse you know
on a profound level in the 21st century
or you know since your uh book in
defense of global capitalism sometimes
they'll say oh yeah you can see it
everywhere because people are dying
sooner and you know everything is junk
now and you know people are not working
and all of that but they kind of grant
that no actually the problem is we have
so much stuff now everybody's distracted
from everything and then there's this
criticism that comes not exclusively but
the the resurgent part of the surging
part of it is from a kind of
anti-liberal right um you know who say
and there there was a vulgar version of
this or a Vox popular version of this uh
articulated by Tucker Carlson who was
like yeah you know we get a lot more
plastic crap in our lives but we don't
you know have any meaningful Community
you um engage Patrick Denine and
American academic who's an illiberal
right-winger who says you know
liberalism has been tried and it fails
and it fails partly because it it it
generates loose connections and we don't
know how to live our lives is he on to
something I don't think he he is he
makes a very
strong case
rhetorically he he explains that we're
becoming increasingly separate
autonomous non-relational selves complet
with rights and defined by our Liberty
but insecure powerless afraid and alone
and of course we can all understand what
he's getting at because life is tough
and it's we often feel like but you hear
this like you know uh you know men young
men have no close personal friends
according to survey nobody's having sex
anymore um you know the I you know the
last time people had people over their
hous is like a thousand years ago I mean
all of these indicators are are those
not happening or are those just
misinterpreted you know there's an
epidemic of headlines saying that
there's a loneliness epidemic but when
researchers look at it it's very
difficult to find something like that
yes we spend more time alone than we
used to there are more single households
than before but it seems like we enjoy
that it seems like actually single
households and people who spend less
time with others also often say that
they're less lonely than others so it
might be that we're also choosing our
relationships in ways that make them
more fruitful and important to us and we
adapt them to to our individual and this
is somebody anybody who grew up in a
household where you had to share a
bedroom like you know when you can
afford it you get your own bedroom right
I mean on some and that's kind of a
banal level and I'm also now I'm put in
mind that I'm talking to a Swedish
person and a Scandinavian and somebody
who's watched a lot of Bergman movies so
you're like no the greatest world you
know imaginable is one where I am alone
in my own dark thoughts all the time
right but you you do quote a uh meta
study or a meta
analysis uh you know that shows like
mental health issues which we're
constantly told we're in this epidemic
of loneliness and we're in you know
deaths of Despair and people are sadder
and more apart than ever but when you
actually look at the social science on
this it it's not there right yeah quite
right and we have to make the
reservation that the pandemic might have
have influenced this we we're probably
seeing a rise of certain
mental uh illness conditions more
loneliness but that's if anything that's
an argument against the case that
mobility and freedom results in us being
alone and weak and and Afraid um but
overall when it when you really look at
the data it doesn't seem like um we're
seeing a Rise um globally over the
population when it comes to mental
illness or loneliness or anything like
that um what we have been seeing is that
many conditions that we saw before we've
started to use another terminology to
describe them often a mental illness
terminology can you uh explain that a
little so you were you were sadden you
had to lay down for two weeks that's
what we used to say about parents when
Mom was feeling bad now it's depression
now it's a clinical condition and that's
something else and for good and ill I
think we're over diagnosing some of
these things we we might have have
turned too often to to doctors when we
should have talked to a friend but I
also think this is a way in which we
take some of these problems seriously
for the first time you know in my
parents generation they would never talk
about how they felt and their mental
conditions yeah you'd go to a doctor if
you lost a leg but you would never do it
if you broke your heart or or anything
like that and in some ways that the
stigma is gone even though it might
result in overdiagnosis it's also a sign
that we're actually we care and we're
trying to do something and if we get the
right therapy cognitive behavior therapy
it has excellent results so doing that
is not a sign of a sick Society I think
it's a sign of healthy
Society um I guess you know when I I
would think everybody who reads the
capitalist Manifesto is going to walk
away like okay here are the arguments
that I keep hearing that are describing
the reality I live in it's a really
powerful rebuttal to that um and then
I'm left wondering what are the you know
how do how do you change someone's mind
because a lot of people are invested in
the idea that these are if not the worst
of all possible times we're starting to
get there like our orbit is is degrading
and we're falling back into the Earth
and getting burned up on the re-entry or
something I don't know what the right
metaphor is how you know I I guess my
question is like your book is part of of
of an answer to that it's like no like
let's start by talking about what's
actually going on and and and it's
filled with a lot of kind of stories of
you know actual people and individuals
to illustrate these larger principles
but what are you know what are the
stories that should be told at a higher
level to get people to be like stop
being so pessimistic stop being so
Swedish you know about this and you know
get out and play in the
sun yeah that that is exactly the reason
why I wrote this book because it's an
uphill battle right now and I've noticed
that you tend to
ruin good dinner parties by explaining
that that we're not going to die and I
understand we should care about global
warming but look 40 countries have been
able to reduce carbon dioxide emissions
in absolute terms while growing their
economies in the past decade so and
people are often invested in their
problems and in the problems of the
world and it's part of their identity
and the fact that they care about it
it's it's important to them so telling
them that look this it's actually better
than you think might be threatening
ironically uh but I don't really find
that among uh
um I find that when you go into single
aspects when you look at every single
data point if you're talking
about
Extinction uh of of mammals or if you're
thinking talking about carbon dioxide
separately if you're talking about
poverty in Bangladesh people pay
attention to those things so and they
listen to the data and they're
interested in the story so perhaps we
might not need the biggest grandest
narratives because they are also the
most threatening if I'm telling
everybody that it's a good way to get
detention to tell people that look we've
had the 20 best years in human history
but it's also it's a way of starting a
conversation but it's also threatening
and it seems weird but when I talk to
them about their concerns in on various
issues then it's possible to break
through so I think we need a million
small stories that relate all of these
things and that's why I tried to capture
so many different areas of of lived
experience in the book what um how many
uh kids do you have three and how what
what's the age range 12 13 16 okay and
what do you um you know do they seem
convinced that obviously you know they
may not be the right age to just
disagree with you reflexively or not but
I mean do they seem optimistic about the
future or you know yeah I mean I guess
let's start with that well they do come
home from school and tell me that we're
going to die suffocating in Plastics
from the oceans as well so uh there is
that and I noticed that among the
generation however I don't know why if
it's genetics or something else but they
tend to be on the more optimistic side
than their classmates and um you know
thinking about solutions to things so
for example my oldest son is sort
of always trying to make school projects
about nuclear power and how we can make
it cheap and safe and this will give us
unlimited energy for the future is there
it I just as a side note uh is you know
does nuclear do you think nuclear power
is going to make a
Resurgence I think so but we're going to
need something better and I think
actually we ruined it the last time
around by having the government picking
nuclear power as the winner that that's
what we thought in the 1960s and let's
just build them right now big expensive
because the technology wasn't right
there and less safe than it could have
been if we had done it slowly steadily
step by step um the way we do it in any
other kind of innovation but the moment
the government gets involved it's sort
of one big package and it became too
expensive and difficult to continue with
it now we are seeing it in another let's
hope we don't repeat that mistake
because at least on
the on paper there are some kind of
promising smaller scale cheaper
Solutions do you um for your kids what
you know say in 10 years what are there
indicators where you would say oh my God
like you know indicators for their life
and their well-being where if they were
going in the wrong direction to' be like
holy cow we really do need to change
what we're doing
right yeah what would that be which
indicators well obviously um as a parent
any kind of mental illness loneliness
thing and I think that's a reason why we
get so many headlines about this that is
worrying when we when we see that and
that's also a reason why we shouldn't
take those things too lightly and just
talk about epidemics and the worry about
cell phones and stuff like that because
it's kind of self-reinforcing um in a
way
um it's it's interesting that yes we've
seen a rise in mental illness among
teenagers especially girls in the US but
hey we use cell phones in Sweden too and
in Japan too why haven't we seen the
same things so there are always some
problems in some areas some places we do
have to look at broader sections of of
the world population if we're going to
find some cause and effect but sorry I I
wonderand away from your your questions
so but that's one indicator obviously
any kind of self harm self-destructive
behavior is worrying definitely and also
obviously opportunities in the economy
getting jobs and being able to start
start businesses being able to afford to
buy an apartment right yeah that's
always for the from the parents persp I
realized this long after my parents have
died that the sign of success is that
your kids don't live with you right you
know and you know for a long time that
was not something civilization could uh
could afford right you know
multigenerational families are like you
know that's nobody's first choice I
think right right to to me if there's
anything that's important it's that they
get and have and keep the sense that
they are able to affect their own lives
and do something about it well let me
throw something at you and it's you know
I don't get to talk to Swedish
intellectuals very often not because
there aren't a lot of them it's just you
know we travel in different circles but
I was thinking a lot lately of uh a work
by par logis the uh Swedish Nobel Prize
winner who is best known at least in the
US for his novel barabus uh which is a
great Christian existentialist novel
came out in 1950 and it's about the guy
who gets freed in the place of Jesus and
then is you know so he's given a new
life that he didn't earn you know and he
doesn't really know what to do I've been
thinking a lot lately that that's kind
of where we are as a society certainly
in the US in Europe I think increasingly
in the world where we have to be the
masters of our own Destinies and I took
for granted that that is incredible and
liberating um I think it's also an
unbelievably anxiety inducing
particularly at the society-wide level
is this the real crisis it's not a one
of material or moral progress It's that
we are all you know Copus and we've got
to choose what Boulder we're doing and
why we're doing it and how do we get
happy doing that yeah yeah I'm I'm fond
of this Old Eastern European proverb if
you don't have food you have one problem
but if you have food you have a thousand
problems and obviously you start to
think about your life and every aspect
of it and how you're going to make sure
that things work out for the best and
obviously that's anxiety inducing as
logerquist or kir God would have pointed
out um until you consider the
alternative um because every time you
look at what do people say what do the
young say about their lives and whether
they're happy subjective well-being and
so on yes this sense that there's so
much choice and you don't know what to
do with your life is it
feels in in your stomach um but if you
don't have those options if you don't
have those freedoms those who say that
they have the least chance to change
their lives and decide what to do when
it comes to education career and so on
then it shows up in clinical di clinical
diagnosis it feels uh then it turns into
mental illness so there are different
versions of anxiety and some are are
better than others but I do understand
the Temptation you know
we we come from a long prehistory of
living in lands and and tribes and
someone telling us what to do and
sometimes it feels liberating just
having that strong man telling you I
know the answer to to the question uh
and it takes some
um some novels and some research to
really find out that the way in which we
really create more decent societies and
more fulfilled lives is not to just
follow that one rule but to find the way
within us and and this is your in your
uh discussion of Patrick Denine and
other people like him that's the
reputation of it right that they think
because there are multiple ways or
people are finding their own paths that
that comes at the cost of society or
meaning or culture but in fact it's kind
of the the ultimate Victory it's so
strange when you read them and their
idea about what Classical liberalism and
free markets are all about out because
they think it's just these institutions
and they say they can't give you meaning
of life it's just sort of property
rights and free exchange that's not
enough of course it's not enough I I
mean we need something more but what
that's the question and I'm not sure
Denine knows what we need uh he might
well he certainly doesn't know what you
need right exactly and I I need love and
friendship and I need good books by
Mario Vargas yosa and I need a this a
mercy record at last after just having
played live for three decades now uh
those are things that give me meaning
but it wouldn't give denin meaning um so
it's it's important to point out that
there are many different ways to many
different versions of meaning and I
think we can pick that up by looking at
polls because all these claims from
Denine and others they're so very rarely
backed up by any kind of empirical data
they just point out that this you should
all be miserable because how could you
vulgar people ever find meaning in Taco
Tuesday and bad TV shows yeah I know he
doesn't that's why intellectuals
shouldn't run our lives because they
have another set of preferences than
than we do in another meaning of life
but we can pick up in polls how people
are doing in individualist societies
compared to collectivist ones Rich
societies compared to poor ones and no
matter what intellectuals say it shows
up again and again a very clear pattern
people say that they're more happier
more more subjective well-being enrich
free societies individualist societies
they feel less lonely than they do in
poorer and less free societies and they
also think that they have more friends
whom they can rely upon they also say
that they're more willing to help others
when they are in need so all these
indicators once you stop being so myopic
and just looking at one year in the US
but look around the world compare
different systems different populations
then you see that we're actually not in
the best of possible worlds but the best
one so far all right we're going to
leave it there we've been talking with
Johan Norberg whose latest book is the
capitalist Manifesto Yan thanks so much
for talking to Reza thank you very much
for having
[Music]
me